I mentioned this a couple of days ago
and I had a friend a Hollywood friend I
love saying that I only have one
Hollywood friend so he says hey you know
who taught Brad Pitt how to fly-fish and
that movie a river runs through it he
was listening on the show and I said who
and he goes uh Melissa Etheridge did and
her swimming pool and I went what so I
mentioned it on the air and then all of
a sudden I start to see tweets where
people are reaching out to Melissa
Etheridge to see if she'll come on the
program and I'm thinking Melissa
Etheridge has got better things to do to
come on this program and lo and behold
fritzy reaches out and Melissa Ethridge
the singer-songwriter guitarist joining
us on the program good morning Melissa
thanks for joining us good morning Dan
first time long time okay when did you
start to hear about this that we were
talking about this and how did it get me
I just heard it a couple days ago just
it was a tweet from a guy he was really
hey I heard you talk Brad Pitt out of
fly fish is this true go chiefs
you know okay explain that to me because
Brad Pitt is he had to audition for a
river runs through it correct yeah this
was back this it this was one of his
first movies after Thelma and Louise
okay and he there was a bunch of us sort
of Midwestern Hollywood wannabes trying
to make it and he he has he knew that I
loved to fish like I was born and raised
in Kansas my father was a sporting guy
he was a basketball coach high school
basketball coach and just a real
sporting guy he taught me how to fish
very young and it's just been a big part
of my life and he knew that I knew how
to fish and fly fish and so he said look
I have to audition for this movie a
river runs through it and I said well
come over and I'll show you just I just
showed him how to cast just to where he
could look like he knew how to fish and
then of course for the movie the you
know the big professionals came in and
taught him how to do everything but this
was just in the beginning and we were
you know in Hollywood fly-fishing in my
swimming pool but he wasn't famous at
the time but he's from Missouri though
Melissa didn't even know how to fish
growing up you know I
depends on the family not Elvis knew my
father was you know deep Missouri born
and raised kind of poor and you know
they fish to live so that's different
but okay so then you see the movie and
what do you think when you see Brad Pitt
did you get credit at all no no I didn't
get credit no I didn't one credit it was
just I was helping a buddy out you know
yeah but Brad didn't say you know I
never could have done this without
Melissa Etheridge because he could have
he didn't I love the fact that you
invite him to your pool but do you have
neighbors who could have seen this or no
this was this was up in the Hollywood
Hills and you know it was just it was
just a fun thing he's he had been a
friend when we were younger he he was
good friends we used to watch Chiefs
games together he's a big Chiefs fan too
and when did you become a die-hard
Chiefs fan Oh 1970 the Super Bowl you
know when the the only time we won the
Super Bowl and it was just such a I was
you know eight years old and I just I
remember it so well that whole season
you know how excited my family was and
that the whole town it was just a once
you get that in your blood you're just
you you stay you're there could you
write a song about Patrick mahomes yes I
wrote about Alec Smith a couple years
ago because he was doing good but man
willing what was the song about with
Alex Smith oh it was it was on Good
Morning Football it was a it was just
Alec Smith I love you and you know that
even though he would never throw all the
way down the field dan Patrick mom has
come along and well you know they know
how we are as fans we're all in love
again how about the Ballad of the big
armed man he's just oh I think all of us
in Kansas City just they're just kind of
a gay power mouths are dropped open and
we're every game were like oh my god
when is this
feeling gonna stop but it doesn't stop
it there's always a possibility we've
seen we used to get whooped by Peyton
Manning and John Elway and just you know
always in you know and that Tom Brady
guy in every playoff and we never had
that quarterback that could just you
know create a magic play and I think we
do now and it just is I don't fly it
just feels crazy we've never felt this
way have you done the anthem Kansas City
dance I did I did it last year I did it
during it was the Steelers game or then
they lost they had that we were
undefeated five and oh and then we
played this dealers game and we lost
five in a row I I blame myself you know
but then you also go to Lambeau and you
did the anthem at Lambeau yes well you
know I am I'm married and my wife is a
die-hard Packers fan and you know happy
wife happy life
so I took her to Lambeau I took her
about three years ago and and met all
the folks really beautiful folks Lambos
oh now I heard you saying I'm not saying
Lambeau itself is yummy because you know
it's a little old and it's got some beer
and bratwurst and you know but but the
people there it is it is amazing the
whole feeling of football and how that
city holds it holds their their team and
the whole the responsibility I just it's
it makes me you know my father passed
away so I really miss my father when I
go and and feel that sort of football
feeling that they have there and the
reverence it reminds me of him
so it's yummy to me I yeah I needed to
get the full context of your quote and
then one of my guys read it to me and I
said oh I thought she was saying Lambeau
was yummy and I and I thought maybe
you're talking about the brats and you
know the whole team no no no I was gonna
sing you a meet Friday song but I'm a
vegetarian so it's just not you know
smoking the tofu is just not gonna be a
good song I'm sorry
now I had Will Ferrell record a song for
me it's called stat of the day now oh
yeah okay now I'm gonna I'm gonna play
it for you and if it it's something hits
you and you feel like maybe you want to
do a stat of the day for us this is how
Will Ferrell sounded when he did it stat
everyday sad as a day that passed out of
the day stat of the day here comes that
what stat of the day
what do you think oh well you know Will
Ferrel is fine he's you know you got
your guitar oh I can hear it all righty
I love it have to put you on
speakerphone
here we go let me give him let me give a
formal introduction here all right here
you go
a Grammy Oscar winning singer-songwriter
25th anniversary of her iconic yes I am
album Chiefs fan thinks Lambeau is yummy
and here to offer us a stat of the day
is the great Melissa Etheridge
[Music]
comes the stand of the day
I love you that's awesome that's awesome
how often do you just pick up the guitar
like and you know on a daily basis every
day I've done it since I was about 8 so
I've just done it a lot but every day
you pick it up
well I wouldn't say every day those days
I don't pick it up but most days days
you hate it no I never hate it I love it
yeah you know I was just curious about
that where you look at it I never I
don't think I'm wired to play guitar no
you're wired to think to think sports
and you do it every day right yeah but I
want to play guitar can I do both well I
want to play why is it that you know you
get musicians who want to be athletes or
actors and it's always everybody wants
to be something other than what they are
yeah well we all have an appreciation
for people that can do you know fun
amazing stuff
I'd love to you know if you need like
somebody to sing for you I'd be more
than happy to help you like a background
vocal careful now I play New York all
the time I don't care how often you play
New York you don't want me singing a
background now were you on tour with
blondie and Joan Jett yeah a couple of
years ago really fun I did a show with
with all both of them it's just just
great I mean you know it's funny I think
the atmosphere is changing now used to
be you can only have one woman like on
the radio at a time or one woman that in
a concert lineup but nowadays people are
getting a little braver and saying that
women headlining doesn't turn men away
so it's they like rock and roll but Joan
Jett has always been one of my favorites
Joanie never compromised she just that's
who she is and take it or leave it and
you know I love that but that's that's
the way you've been to and even Deborah
Harry with blondie so well that's the
rock and roll feeling it's like hey I
know you know I don't fit your norms but
come on rock to this let's move so I
know you're up here I think in November
in this area yeah yeah coming back doing
my holiday tour what's that encompass
what's that that's that's
all the hits and all the fun with some
holiday songs put in there I did a I put
out a holiday album a few years ago and
it's just a lot of fun well thank you
for being a good sport we appreciate you
you crushed the song and good luck to
your Chiefs and good luck to your wife's
Packers as well and and thank you for
joining us well thank you so much I hope
to come by and see in person sometime
that sounds great
I appreciate that Thank You Melissa
thank you that's so melissa etheridge of
course it was so awesome
yeah yeah that's us for more Dan Patrick
show to the audience channel 239 on
DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick show
app
[Music]